c'est antoine maintenant c'est quoi un
book un mot que c'est la contraction de
magazine et bouc ce que j'ai dans les
mains ce que vous avancez sa voix la cca
c'est un mix entre un magazine et un
bouquet vous êtes justement voulait les
étudiants futurs journalistes chez nous
actuellement ici à france 3 dans le
cadre de la semaine de la presse à
l'école
à l'origine de ce magazine c'est ça
c'est ça c'est toute la promo de cette
année on était 16 avoir réalisé ce
magazine
pourquoi ce nom étrange hier 45 f 35 en
fait c'est le nom de la salle où on
travaille pendant un an
c'est notre salle notre salle d'étude en
fait on le voit les matchs un support
papier avec beaucoup de photos vous êtes
allés à la rencontre des gens dans leur
intimité vraiment c'est ça et le thème
de cette année c'était travailler
autrement donc on devait tous
s'intéresser à de nouvelles manières de
travailler dans plein de domaines on a
de l'agriculture la restauration la
culture on a plein de choses justement
c'est quoi le métier de journaliste pour
vous de gérer animal banon qui dit pas
grand chose avec ses beaux yeux là
maintenant le métier de journaliste que
vous vous choisissez visiblement à vous
le disais tout à l'heure vous voulez
devenir journaliste ça représente quoi
pour vous le métier alors pour moi le
métier de journaliste est un métier en
perpétuelle évolution c'est se remettre
en question chaque jour avoir une
ouverture d'esprit quasiment infinie
essayer d'être le plus neutre et le plus
objectif possible avoir le souci de
véracité et surtout aimer les gens avoir
envie de leur transmettre quelque chose
une information antoine
moi je dirais un peu la même chose sauf
que moi j'aurais beaucoup de mal à
définir le métier de journaliste je
pense que c'est ce qui m'attire c'est
qu'on peut faire plein de choses sur
plein de support et on peut travailler
de différentes manières et moi c'est ce
qui m'intéresse dans ce métier là elle
était vraie curiosité à propos de
différentes manières vous avez quelques
réalisations concrètes pour france 3
qu'on peut voir sur les réseaux sociaux
on va en découvrir un premier exemple
qui est assez surprenant je crois qu'on
va pas trop en dire finalement ce qui
est sûr c'est que on est écolo toute sa
vie et quand on meurt on pollue
énormément c'est un peu le pitch vous
allez comprendre regardez c'est une
autre écriture une écriture différente
du schéma classique de la télévision
telles qu'on connaît et on en parle
juste après avec nos deux journalistes
en herbe qui sont avec nous dans le
cadre de la semaine de la presse
à l'école on est dans un cimetière à
dijon aujourd'hui qui compte 33 mille
concessions et 138000 défunt et on s'est
demandé combien d'arbres
il a fallu couper pour fabriquer toutes
ces cercueils et c'est d'ailleurs tout
l'interrogation de notre reportage
quelle est l'empreinte écologique de la
fabrication des cercueils et surtout
existe-t-il des alternatives plus
écologiques et on en a trouvé une à peu
près une heure de dijon à saint martin
en bresse chez monsieur georges
braissant et gens présents ils
fabriquent ces cirques allons cellulose
depuis 1992 alors on l'a rencontrée nous
a expliqué un petit peu comment il
travaillait surtout surtout on a testé
et on vous laisse découvrir ça tout de
suite
six cercueils qui est en moi entre
autres se dégrade
si vous voulez bien entre temps le
cercueil en carton se dégrade à 90 jours
c'est à dire que ces prix sont de
l'ordre de 1900 à 2000 unités et un
cercueil en carton à 240
je pensais pas rentré que sitôt à
l'internât c'est fait on est venu
[Musique]
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on
sort du reportage classique en jouant
sur l'humour est l'incarnation on est
dans une autre écriture
c'est en fait c'est une autre écriture
je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment
l'humour notre cas c'est pas lui mots
qu'on a voulu prôné sinon ce reportage
c'est plus une écriture à double entrée
j'avais manenti filmer les plans
extérieur et moi je filmais de
l'intérieur avait que mon téléphone
c'est comme ça qu'on a les images de
l'intérieur du cercueil donc c'est ce
qu'on a voulu tester et on a une même le
cercueil en carton voilà et on a une
autre écriture par par le sujet aussi
c'est un sujet on peut dire atypique je
pense c'est pas le genre de sujet qu'on
al'habitude forcément devoir et on s'est
dit qu'en mixant les deux ans on pouvait
avoir un produit un peu un peu hybride
et innovant ces produits hybrides et
innovants les retrouve pas forcément sur
la chaîne de télé classique comme ceux
qui sont avec nous ce matin faut aller
les chercher sur le sur les écrans
connectés c'est ça c'est ça sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les sites internet
sur la chaîne youtube de france 3
bourgogne sont ligne on peut les
retrouver ici
oui plein de choses un clic qui sont
faites et qu'on ne soupçonne pas parce
que vous êtes plusieurs à être venus ici
en immersion dans france 3 pour nous
faire vivre finalement votre votre
jeunesse
on va dire ça comme ça avec une autre
expérience c'est ça c'est ça c'est une
opportunité je pense de pouvoir rentrer
ici est importé nous cette cette
fraîcheur et ce regard sur sur le
numérique qui se développe de plus en
plus et nous on a beaucoup de choses à
apprendre des journalistes qui
travaillent ici et de tous les moyens
qui sont mis à disposition sur le
numérique
comment vous avez vécu maintenant cette
absence de contrainte finalement parce
que on vous a carrément donné carte
blanche
oui c'est ça on devait juste traiter
d'un sujet autour de la thématique
environnementale
mais sinon on avait carte blanche et je
dirais que c'était à double tranchant
l'atout c'était que du coup on
bénéficiait d'une énorme liberté on
pouvait vraiment tout faire mais du coup
c'était un océan infini de possibilités
et on finit par avoir peur de se noyer
mais finalement c'était une expérience
vraiment enrichissante
vous avez travaillé en duo c'est ça mais
on a travaillé tous les deux mais ça
c'est important
chaque duo choisi son sujet ça se passe
comme ça on avait le thème général
c'était l'environnement et ensuite
chacun se disait un sujet est une forme
donc on a des sujets plus humoristique
avec des sketches ou des vidéos en face
calmes comme font les youtuber par
exemple et des reportages un peu plus
classique on a même de l'animation du
début à la fin du gros porteur
mais justement tu renvoies rhin avec un
bel extrait c'est un outil de
modification génétique dont vous ne
parlerez aprés mais il peut changer
notre vie vous allez comprendre pourquoi
c'est une animation c'est une autre
écriture encore une fois avec des
journalistes en herbe
l'avenir c'est eux et ces images de
ségou bientôt regarder
vous avez toujours rêvé d'être unique en
voici grâce à chris marquès 9 les
ciseaux génétique révolutionnaire
inventée par une microbiologiste
française en 2012
il découpe laden avec une précision
chirurgicale modifier l'expression d'un
gène inactivé ou le remplacer est devenu
un véritable jeu d'enfant modique
plus d'informations sur notre site si à
50 ans on n'est pas modifié c'est qu'on
a loupé sa vie il nous à sarah quittent
génétique et le tour est joué
en une dizaine de générations plus +
nousty mais c'est oui
la véritable génocide d'ailleurs
l'essayer a déclaré chris pas comme une
ambition massif potentiel alors vous
imaginez on est encore très loin de
connaître parfaitement l'adn certains
scientifiques craignent que ces
mutations ne passe la barrière des
espèces et se propage chez d'autres
animaux alors des ciseaux qu'on peut
aller chercher carrément sur une
plateforme de vente en ligne c'est pas
c'est pas une extrapolation qui
viendrait d'une autre planète exil en a
existé
on les trouve pour une centaine d'euros
sur internet oui c'est ça en tout cas ça
soulève de nombreuses questions éthiques
on n'a pas le temps de les traiter ici
mais certains que on peut traiter d'un
sujet très sérieux qui peut changer la
face du monde de manière humoristique en
tout cas de manière décalée
c'est totalement ce qu'elles ont voulu
faire et l'animation c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'avait pas forcément eu
l'habitude de mettre en pratique et
elles se sont dit c'est un vrai défi
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément eu de
cours là dessus et nous intervenons
avait pas forcément de formation sur
l'animation et elles se sont lancé là
dedans et et ça donne ce produit qui est
plutôt plutôt réussie est plutôt amusant
vie antoine manon
vous informez aujourd'hui parce que
votre génération y née avec les écrans
vous allez chercher l'info nous alors on
s'informe
moi je m'informe quand même par des
médias traditionnels mais également il
faut pas faire du fayotage sais pas mais
oui bien sûr je pense qu'on aura plus
tendance à se tourner par exemple vers
les réseaux sociaux et instagram
aujourd'hui fait partie de notre
quotidien et à certains médias qui sont
présents sur instagram
on peut par exemple parler de combiner
avec leur story qui sont quand même
amusante et qui essayait toujours de
proposer de nouveaux formats ma part et
les réseaux sociaux et puis pas mal
d'applications je télécharge souvent des
applications de médias plus
traditionnels ou moins et surtout
j'écoute la radio en fait les matins
aussi c'est mon premier mon premier
geste pour l'information le matin en
fait très bien vous vous êtes en master
aux médias je le précise avec nous
encore alors pour maintenant c'est un
stage pour vous c'est une alternance
la différence c'est quoi mano entre
alternance et stages
maintenant la différence c'est que cette
année nous avions cours dans notre
formation du lundi au mercredi et le
jeudi et le vendredi était réservé à
l'alternance c'est à dire qu'antoine
était à france 3 bourgogne le jeudi et
le vendredi
alors que moi le jeudi et le vendredi
j'étais à l'université pour travailler
sur des projets et j'ai rejoint france 3
bourgogne en stage qu'à partir du mois
de mars
aucune formation pluridisciplinaire on
va dire pour valoriser le travail en
équipe et et favoriser la prise
d'initiatives pour peut-être devenir
journaliste en tout cas c'est bien parti
bonne chance à tous les deux un sacré
avec nos listes et la fin de l'émission